[موسيقى]
المراه بالاضافه الى الاعمال المنزليه
وتحضير الطعام وتنظيف المنزل تعمل ايضا في
الارض وتحلب البقره وحتى تشارك في الامور
الماليه بالمنزل وتوزيع المصاريف بشكل
صحيح مثلا على متطلبات الزراعه والمواد
الغذائيه هذه الامور كلها تتم بشكل جماعي
والمراه تشارك فيها ايضا
كنا اربع نسوه عندما اتينا الى هنا انا
وامي اولا ثم صديقتنا انضمت الينا مع
ابنتها وكنا نقوم بالاعمال التي يقوم بها
الرجال لانك عندما تعيش على الارض فعليك
ان تحفر وتحمل الاشياء الثقيله وتنشر
الخشب وتقطعه وتقص العشب كنا نحن نفعل هذا
نحن الفتيات
وامهاتنا كن يطبخن ويخسرنا وبعدها
بالتدريج انضم الينا اناس جدد
[موسيقى]
سنضيف هذا السماد الى المزروعات من دونه
تنمو فقط الاعشاب الضاره التي ستنبت في كل
الاحوال